you're that peacemaker guy yeah evil
super villain not a super villain that's
a misconception
peacemaker is a highly trained weapons
specialist what the hell is that it's a
grenade i tied to a russian tank shell
how many people does this blow up i
don't know this morning
[Music]
he has a questionable backstory made the
only choice i could funny how often the
only choice in killing people coincides
peacemaker is a trained assassin that
wears a costume a bright red shirt and
white pants aren't exactly conducive to
lurking in the shadows people see this
uniform and strikes fear in their hearts
who the other people at the village
people try out
peacemaker is recruited to join a secret
team for a mission that probably doesn't
have a large chance of success you don't
want to believe in miracles that's on
you he fights for his values what he
believes is good i made a vow to have
peace at any cost no matter how many men
women and children i need to kill to get
it
no good right now the world needs a
psychopath and you're the only one i got
oh my god
he's hugging me dad grab my phone i
don't want to move